take a look at the season numbers for
lancelin we talked about how good and
consistent he has been in his 10 starts
a 5 and 2 record with a very nice two
and a half era good whip under one
69 strikeouts to 21 walks and how about
that opponent's batting average so
here's marcus simeone
that one is lying to left and that's a
base hit
down the line solac over to cut it off
la stella's going to get to third stop
there marcus simeon eases into second
with the double and these are in
business here in the first so nobody out
the infield's back and here's biscotti
and lynn working out of this stretch
biscotti it's a slow tapper towards
short that's going to get a run
so la stella scores piscotty puts it in
play and the a's have an early run one
nothing the big right-hander for the
oakland a's frankie montas
making his ninth start of the season and
much like lance lynn
trying to put a few outings
in the past behind him
nitto doer in the cleanup spot he does
have a couple of home runs in this
series frankie delivers and here's the
1-2 pitch it's pulled to the right side
right to tony kemp at second he throws
to first for the out and the inning is
over
and after one final game of the series
the a's lead the ranger is one nothing
glenn got a strikeout in the first
inning of matt olsen moriano has not had
a big year against the rangers he hasn't
really had a big year period
he goes after the high heat to gone in
the second derrick dietrich first up for
the rangers against frankie montas in
the bottom of the second this one hit
well out to left field and gone
how about that bolt to left field by
derrick dietrich
to get the rangers on the board and tie
the game at one that is opposite field
and a line shot off the bat at derrick
derrick dietrich an absolute missile
mathis the ninth place hitter the fish
to jeff mathis has swung onto her mist
though as a fastball by him
96. to hayden left at third the ranger
is tied up on the home run by dietrich
lance lynn taking some time getting that
right foot planted on the rubber now
here comes the 3-2 and a swing and a
miss fastball down around the knees gets
simeon for the final out in the inning
lance records his third strikeout so
lead off man aboard speedy lyodi tavares
and here's kinder philipe who had a base
hit in the first inning
reaches for it
not at second and olson keeps his foot
on the bag and that's a 4-6-3 double
play now frankie comes back with a 2-2
and it's a slider he offers and misses
and down he goes second k from otos
full count
on piscotty strikes out here to start
the fourth lanceland continuing to use
this fastball in a big way the one two
bit swinging a miss so five strikeouts
on the day and they make it 1400 career
strikeouts now
for lance lynn
the one two swing and a miss
lin strikes out the side here in the top
of the fourth inning rugnet odor derek
dietrich and anderson tajeda to stand in
against frankie motas 1-2 swing and a
miss high octane 98 blows away odor and
there's one god in the bottom of the
fourth inning one two backdoor sliders
strike three called freezes dietrich and
he is gone looking fastball swinging a
miss exploding at 97 more high octane
from motos as he caged the side and we
go to the fifth one run just one hit for
oakland one run three hits for texas
lynn delivers
struck him out looking
so punch out number seven for lancelin
and he's retired 15 men in a row
the last hit in this game was the double
by anderson ceja with nobody out in the
bottom of the second now the one-two
pitch is swung out of miss fastball 98
inside and frankie montas is matching
lancelin pitch for pitch don't shrank
away from putting this inning to bed
with lance lynn it's where he has
excelled this year swinging a miss and
piscotty
tied in knots for the final out of the
sixth inning get your cleanup hitter to
the plate and a run scoring
opportunity big spot for odor
and there's a swing in that ball hit
high in the air deep out to right it's
gone
a three-run shot by odor
and the rangers take a 4-1 lead
and in a huge spot
luke neto door delivers he knew it right
away and so did chuck morgan they
started playing that music before that
ball hit grossman at second canna at
first jonah heim the hitter 3-2
this one
oh lined over toward third base and
snared out of the air by connor falefa
great diving catch to his left
4-1
and here's jeff mathis he is going and
this ball hit well out to left field
grossman angling back looks up dawn a
home run
mathis with a two run shot
at some big insurance runs for the
rangers
but stella left-handed hitter
stella hits one high and deep to right
field
eli white leaps can't get it that's a
home run for tommy la stella so that
makes it six to two fifth home run of
the year his first as a member of the
athletics well now the knees just need
one more base runner to get the tying
runway but
off the end of the bat and that may work
and it's gonna work as it's picked up by
connor falefa but he can't do anything
with it
cannon is gonna come in to score to make
it six to three two pitch
and got him swinging and that's the ball
game so the a's do get a run and they do
get the tying run to the plate in the
ninth inning
but they come up short